can you tell what race I am just by
hearing my voice correct
turns out Americans are pretty good at
guessing your race just by hearing your
voice
it's called linguistic profiling and we
all do it there are certain auditory
cues that give us subtle hints about who
we're talking to a lot of black
Americans speak what's referred to as a
a VE our African American vernacular
English AV is non-rhotic meaning that
like a British accent there are no R
sounds at the end of words or at the end
of syllables John Fleming is a speech
and dialect coach for movies and video
games generally speaking there's the th
sounds the these'
and the the get replaced with something
generally at T or a D there's a few
other vowels and things but it kind of
keeps going and going and it gets kind
of into the weeds a bit when it comes to
being on the phone though black people
will often try to sound more white yes
mister ribbon I would love to have the
opportunity to sit with you to discuss
some of our products it's a form of
code-switching
or in this case alternating between two
different dialects these are the gravy
but my column right
oh good morning customer service my name
is Philip black people talking white is
having a real moment in media right now
sorry to bother you as a movie about a
black salesman whose career only takes
off when he starts talking white you
want to make some money here use your
weight Louis hey mr. Kramer
this is Langston from regal view and
black claims mint is a movie about a
black detective who infiltrates the KKK
by pretending to be white over the phone
god bless white America the idea is to
speak in what's called the standard
accent the standard accent is the one
spoken by the majority group or the
socially advantaged group
Olivia King is a psychologist at Harvard
she's working on a project that explores
the hidden biases we hold
if you speak with the standard accent
you're judged as being more intelligent
more competent more credible more
hireable
now having a regional accent or a
non-standard accent now you're not
getting those advantages you're seen as
less credible or less hireable these
biases are implicit it's
in charlottesville tiki torch racism
it's much more discrete than that the
most basic way of understanding implicit
bias is by thinking about the
associations we make if two things occur
together over and over again in our
experience we link them together salt
and pepper
day and night bread and butter these
types of associations are helpful but
there are some that aren't now if I say
the word genius you're probably thinking
of some collector's edition white dude
now if I say the word criminal voices
aren't just sounds in a lot of ways
they're auditory faces so when you hear
a voice you can in some sense piece
together what the person on the other
end of the phone can look like roughly
how old they are their gender where they
come from but the interesting thing is
that you can also form impressions about
character so how intelligent someone is
how competent how likeable how
trustworthy and these impressions can be
flawed right a lot of these things might
have a basis in your implicit biases or
things that you've heard portrayals
you've seen on television and so when
people are doing something like
conducting a voice interview often the
implicit biases they have about voice
can influence the decisions that they're
making every black American is bilingual
we speak street vernacular and we speak
job interview in order to combat some of
these implicit biases black people
myself included try to sound as white as
possible
I sound like Bill Gates impersonating
your mailman why hello there I'm
wondering if there any positions
available oh no I don't mind waiting
like this changing your voice actually
work a study in 2001 found that
landlords would make racist snap
judgments to callers with certain
dialects compared with whites blacks
were less likely to get callbacks less
likely to be told there was an apartment
available
and more likely to get their credit
question however blacks who code
switched fared better than those who
didn't
code switching helps in other areas too
and actually done lemon is a very good
example because to become this main host
that he is he's talked about how he had
to change cuz he's from New Orleans and
he had did any conscious they had to
change his accent for the sake of moving
up at CNN the President of the United
States is racist instead of changing the
way we speak maybe we should change the
way we listen I might be able to tell
your race from your voice but that
doesn't tell me anything about your
character
there's tons of black mail for you real
quick I don't want no smooth